i saw this man yesterday as we rehearsed
in the news studios at nfl network and
he took an overnight flight to tampa
florida where he will be calling monday
night football on westwood one with
kevin harlan calling in on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line here on
the rich eisen show is my buddy kurt
warner how are you kurt i'm doing good
my man how are you i'm doing fine uh
let's do some weather on the zeros here
uh on the rich eisen show is it's
is it a bad night for football
let's hope it's not a bad night still
early here but uh yeah just opened the
shades and peeked outside and there's
wind blowing and there's rain coming
down
um at the moment so we'll see how that
that plays out over the next few hours
but uh at the moment uh it wouldn't be a
great night especially for a domer like
myself it wouldn't be a great night for
football well then let's let's just
front load the conversation it's florida
so it could be over in an hour and then
it could be beautiful and then come back
in time for kickoff uh who who would the
uh the inclement weather um
uh give an advantage to
well it's funny because i was thinking
about that as soon as i saw the rain and
you know the one thing you say to
yourself is well the cowboys need to
kind of slow down
um you know this this bucks offense and
you get a little rain and weather and
maybe it's less throwing the football
and it's more running the football and
so maybe a lower scoring game which is
advantage to the cowboys but then you
have to flip over to the other side and
you say to yourself well yeah but the
cowboys know zach martin um you thought
coming in with dak being back where they
could hold up and keep up with this this
bucks team was with those you know three
wide receivers on the outside and dak
throwing the football down the field so
if that slows them down
does that give a bigger advantage to
that bucks defense and what the bucks
were able to do running the football
down the stretch so you could see it go
both ways um i just think that the bucks
are the better team here and so uh
whether they have to run the football or
with their defensive front if you can't
throw the football i believe it's a
bigger advantage for the bucks even
though it might appear on the outside
that it would help the cowboys bucks and
cowboys on on uh i guess thursday night
football uh you do monday night football
with kevin harlan um and you'll be in uh
vegas for the ravens and uh and and
raiders on that front um and so and
ezekiel elliott who i interviewed for uh
tonight's pregame show on westwood one
which i'm hosting in advance of your
call with kevin he's that conversation
is coming up in hour number two of this
show
that said kurt warner uh as you're
looking at the bucks and cowboys tonight
is the best roster in the nfl in front
of you tonight for 2021
no no doubt about it uh no doubt about
it the the bucks
have the best roster um i i think on
both sides of the ball is we saw what
that defense became as those guys grew
up and the young guys started to play
and down the stretch and what todd
bowles was able to do
uh i broke it down in the off season a
little bit is one of the great things
when you watch the bucks throughout the
playoffs is every single game
they did something different so a lot of
times you have great defenses that come
out and go back to the bucks of you know
the heyday back at the tampa two bucks
when i played they played cover two uh
ninety percent of the time and then they
would blitz every once in a while they
got really really good at what they did
and that made them great
this team was so great last year because
every game they could come out with a
different game plan they had the front
seven to be able to do whatever they
needed to do the back end was very very
flexible um and so todd bowles was just
able to dial up different things based
on what he saw
the opponent doing and what he felt they
were good at and they could rush with
four uh they could rush with those
linebackers and so you know i know we're
gonna look at the offense and
offensively led by tom brady you're
gonna say yeah you know best uh best
roster in the league but i think it's
just as important what they have
defensively and those guys coming back
and the young guys that are seasoned and
experienced now
man i
i'm excited to watch this team this year
because i know in everybody's mind we're
looking at them 22 returning starters
this team could go you know 17-0 and all
of those things um but i do believe this
team has the ability to win on both
sides of the ball with the talent that
they have can win a lot of different
ways
and it's going to be fun to see if they
can live up to the hype because the hype
is definitely there
not just because of tom brady but
because of all the pieces so then which
team kurt warner do you think that got
close last year
um
has improved the most
whether it's just getting a year older
right or
with continuity or the changes that they
made puts them
closer if not
potentially on par or over the top in
2021
well when i look at the bus team again i
say to myself you've got to win the line
of scrimmage against them all the great
bells and whistles on the outside you
got to win the line of scrimmage
starting with your offensive line
winning the line of scrimmage and and so
when i look at the teams in the nfc i
know a lot of people want to look to the
packers but i believe that's where the
packers have struggled the most the last
two years when they played against san
francisco
san francisco blew them out a couple
years ago because they couldn't manage
those guys up front they struggled again
up front against this bucks team a year
ago and so i don't think it's the
packers i'm looking at some teams and
i'm looking at the nfc west a little bit
49ers are a team that i believe can win
the line of scrimmage if they're healthy
they can run the football and they can
rush the passer that's a team given they
get good play at the quarterback
position that i believe can push the
envelope a little bit a little bit i
look at the rams rams are another team
made the upgrade at the quarterback if
that makes the big move that we think it
could make you got the number one
defense from a year ago you got a guy up
front that obviously can rush the passer
as well as anybody they've always run
the football extremely well they
actually beat the bucks
last year so those are a couple teams
that i'm looking at because i'm looking
at offense and defensive front who can
win the line of scrimmage because i
believe you have to do that if you're
going to knock this buck's team off have
the bills done enough or added enough or
just kept things going
well obviously haven't played yet enough
to get past
the chiefs can the browns maybe with
odell and now adding clowny get past the
chiefs these are the two teams obviously
that kansas city beat
to get to the super bowl last year
yeah you got you got to show me um is
that i do believe buffalo is going to be
really good
again i believe cleveland's going to be
good um you know they'll become back and
so now you say to yourself maybe they're
even more explosive offensively i like
some of the moves they made defensively
so i like both of those teams but you
got to show me you got to show me that
your quarterback can go swing for swing
with patrick mahomes because he is such
an x factor he's such a difference maker
with the things that he brings to the
table that a lot of teams in the afc i
think that are going to be in the mix
you know to make the playoffs but it
always comes down to that position and
that's how i look at the afc is that
there's there's the chiefs and then
there's really everybody else even
though those other teams are good
because of patrick mahomes there's
everybody else and and i want to see
somebody show me that their guy
can hold up against patrick mahomes uh
if they have to get into one of those
kind of games kurt warner my buddy from
uh nfl network he'll be part of
tonight's kickoff show from tampa we're
going to be in our new studios in
los angeles uh kurt uh along with kevin
harlan for westwood one radio calling
tonight's kickoff between the bucks and
the cowboys right here on the rich eisen
show
the best rookie season at quarterback
who's gonna have the best
season of the rookie quarterbacks in
your estimation fully knowing that
justin field's gonna have to wait and
then we're expecting to see trey lance
maybe uh
uh in red zone play and then perhaps
between the 20s what do you think kurt
well
a goal of pre-season first and foremost
and so we take a look at all those guys
and i think all of them did some good
things uh but i thought the two guys
that really shined in the preseason for
me
were zach wilson and mack jones and both
of those guys obviously will be starting
from day one um and so then when i break
those two guys down i just say to myself
i'm not sure that zach
uh has the surrounding cast to really
blow this thing up in his first year
even though i loved what he did in the
preseason i love the changes that
they've made to the office i believe
they're going to create opportunities
for him and i think he's going to play
well this year but i'm going to go with
mac jones uh you know last guy drafted
and everybody wondering what he could be
at this level and is he physically
talented enough i believe he found the
perfect place to play football is that a
we all know the patriots for the 20
years uh had a guy played the game very
similar to him and so they know how to
play football the way that matt jones
plays football i believe josh mcdaniels
is as good as anybody uh at being able
to create opportunities first
quarterback and understanding how to
game plan different weeks with different
things to make their quarterback
successful i believe they've got a good
football team and so
all those factors when i look at how mac
jones plays i think they'll play inside
out very much like they did with tom
brady of two tight ends and their backs
uh and those sorts of things i think it
lends itself to mack jones having a
really really strong year because he's
got a good supporting cast and they will
know how to use him and play it with
strengths now if this was game day
morning
or any other show kurt i'd ask you a
follow-up question about mac a little
bit or what about the other
uh quarterbacks uh that you didn't
mention but what's the name of this show
this is the rich eisen show tell me more
about zach
tell me more about zach tony romo said
he thinks he's got mahomes like
qualities and he could reach that within
two years did you hear tony say that
i i did not and i hate to put
expectations like that on any young kid
but you know that is that
well i mean he definitely has
a talented skill set and the ability to
throw the football in different ways i
think is what makes you say oh little
aaron rodgers a little patrick mahomes
but those guys are so rare and so
special i don't ever want to put that
expectation
on zach but what i loved about zach was
just the way that he managed the games
in the preseason the way he saw the
field got the ball to the right guy was
just tweeting yesterday you know do
these breakdowns and inevitably you get
these people that are saying oh so what
that he threw the ball to the right guy
against third stringers or second
stringers and priests and it's like the
bottom line for a quarterback is you
don't care who's out there as long as
you're seeing what you're supposed to be
seeing and throwing it to the right guy
the right way that's what being a
quarterback is all about and zach did
that extremely well in the preseason it
was limited playing time it was limited
throws but you saw that and if you can
do that i believe that always translates
at the nfl level if you can process
information see what you need to see get
your eyes in the right spot and make the
right decision that always translates um
and then we saw a couple of those
moments like you're talking about rich
where and he's rolling to his right and
you know slinging it kind of sidearm 35
yards down the field um you know corey
davis and you're saying to yourself okay
there's what tony romo was talking about
i see those glimpses as well but but to
me i put it all together i'm not falling
in love with just the physical part of
it what he did mentally in processing in
the preseason is what really really
excites me especially when you say
yourself may not have a great supporting
cast where it's not like bombs away
we're going to win a bunch of
one-on-ones it's playing within the
scheme getting the ball out on time and
making those decisions that's what i
liked about it so
even though nobody really has any
expectations for the jets this year
after seeing what they did offensively
and what he did offensively in the
preseason
i'm actually going into the season going
maybe maybe they're going to be better
than than i thought they were with a new
coaching staff and a new system and a
new energy there and a new quarterback
they may be you know they may surprise
us a little bit in terms of being
competitive i don't know how many games
they win but being more competitive than
i thought going into the off season last
one for you kurt can you put in
perspective the fact that you're going
to be calling a game tonight watching a
banner get raised
um and
buy a team yes
but because in large part that team
raises the banner because of a 44 year
old quarterback about to defend his
seventh
title and his first title defense
uh came as essentially at the expense of
your second
you know and he's been at it for 20
years and he's 44.
can you put in perspective tom brady
for us right now at all court i'm i'm
not sure that we can other than the fact
that here i am at 50 and i still think i
can play now because i'm looking at tom
brady going that guy's doing it still i
think he's given all of us hope that man
you can play
forever and and
none of us should have that hope because
tom brady is rare and he's different and
what he's doing but that to me
is the exciting thing about what tom
brady's doing is that he's he's opening
up a door
uh to other players to think differently
and see the game differently and for us
as fans to go oh my gosh he's 44 years
old and he's playing as well as he's
ever played when is he going to slow
down
the energy and excitement that comes
with
uh you know tonight the banner us
talking about them repeating how good
they are
you're right it all centers around
tom brady and how great he's been and i
just enjoy
watching him compete
every single game out and i enjoy
watching the way that he goes to work
every single day out so i don't know if
you can put it in perspective because
we've never seen anything like it we
will probably never see anything like it
again
but what it does is it says man the
possibilities are open for
for guys and again i'm joking about
being 50 and still playing but there's
still a part of me that goes if he can
do it maybe i could but i think there's
other guys that are saying to themselves
man we don't have to put
a cap on this
like we always did you know everybody
thought well if you certain players by
40 years old you know you got to retire
you got to be done
man this guy gives us an excitement
about the game and excitement about
every year because he's out there
playing and it's going to be the same
tonight when i call the game i can't
wait to watch him play again and see
what he's going to give her what are the
possibilities for a 44 year old
uh you know something we've never seen
before what are the possibilities for
him and this team and i think all of us
say to ourselves
possibilities are endless sure you know
we're expecting them to go win another
championship and for him to compete for
an mvp and that to me is just
mind-blowing when you understand the
scope of what the nfl's been like for
you know for decades have a great time
tonight kurt look forward to listening
to it and i'll see you on game day uh
morning if you will pre-game
tonight uh on nfl network we'll chat
soon all right buddy talk to you that's
the one and only kurt warner hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here